good morning john
10 years ago when we first started
making crash course i had a pretty
specific idea of what kind of help
students needed in high school and
college they needed better tools for
learning and they do and i'm really
proud of the work that crash course has
done in that space but also during those
10 years the outcomes for your typical
high school junior have not been great
84 percent of those kids want to
continue their education after high
school but only about 66 percent of them
will and of the people who go on to
college only 60 of those people will
actually get a degree and so yes about
40 of americans with student loans are
not gonna get a degree my first impulse
when hearing this is this is a learning
problem we need to teach these kids
better and that is part of the problem
but arguably the larger part is just
understanding how this tremendously
complex system works admissions
financial aid credit transfer degree
paths a huge variety of institutions
with a huge variety of systems only 20
of students receive counseling on how
best to pay for college only 30 receive
counseling on how admissions work and
worst of all of course the people for
whom this is hardest are the ones who
get the least support from their
institutions and systems and they're
also the ones who on average have the
least time and money to deal with if you
need more aid and more loans it's much
more likely that you have a full-time or
part-time job during the period during
which you are applying for school you're
also much more likely to have unpaid
work doing child or elder care and
you're less likely to have other people
in your life who have gone through and
experienced these systems who can give
you advice everything from loans to
majors to transferring credits from
community college class election career
counseling financing this is a big messy
bureaucracy and anybody who interfaces
with it even people inside of it will
tell you this they know that it's hard
the less you know the more likely you
are to end up in a situation where
you've boxed yourself into a bad outcome
or you may even be being taken advantage
of by bad institutions the inability to
make an informed decision when it's one
of the most important decisions you're
ever gonna make is a big reason why so
many students end up with loans but no
degree and we understood none of this
when we were first making crash course
so over the last couple of years for you
and me and a lot of people who work at
complexly we've undergone a bit of a
crash course and understanding how
higher education actually works in this
country and we had a little bit of help
with that so i am excited to be telling
you that in partnership with arizona
state university we are launching a new
youtube channel called study hall and
also we are launching a new course on
crash course it's called crash course
how to college a course that takes on
all of the options a person in the u.s
has to face when considering their
future from financial aid to admissions
to majors and careers now we already
made a series of courses with asu under
the name study hall with a specific goal
of helping people with the subjects that
most interfere with a student's ability
to succeed in early college but now we
are launching the study hall project as
a whole youtube channel starting with a
series that i'm extremely excited about
it's called fast guides the fast guides
are a quick but pretty deep dive into
what you're getting yourself into when
you're choosing a major what work can
you expect what skills do you need what
are good alternatives if you want to
switch majors from that major and what
do graduates in that major end up doing
after graduation i am so excited about
these two new things i have learned so
much about why they are necessary please
check out crash course how to college
and the study hall youtube channel and
send them to everyone you know who might
be going to college in the near future
including yourself i have seen the
tremendous amount of work and thought
and care that has gone into these things
and i know that when good people work
hard together they really can help to
solve hard problems so tell everyone you
know there are links in the description
and also probably right here john i'll
see you on tuesday